ああああああ
俺はまたー
パッティングセーターに来ている
米ちゃん肇社長ですそしてこのバッティングセンターの担当者の内田さんですよろしく
お願いします
あの先に言っておきましょう僕野球苦手です
ただ全然張って記念で来た時とがあるんですけども沸点を振っても弾が当たった人パッ
クっ
でも160キロとかそういう方が投げそうならない球を打ちならいいなと思いますね
どうせでもてるのかなっている考えたんですけども
たどり着いた結果が160機よりもっと速い球を練習して一番くると160キロが遅く
見えるんじゃないかという説がありまして
猫のパッティングが水でランキロぐらいまでています
なんて読まれていますに者イエロー
ブーブー意見書 here よしあっ200 k 様
頭を見てみましょうそれくらいのスピード化っていうのが確認されていないと思うんで
1回に威力をボギーで行けます
ボディに受けちゃダメです3弱って現を見てみます midi すごいを3分に役立っ
て書いてあるよ
宮島で廃業せきのさきました来ましたはいん
いただきましたまずめるみお
じゃないよこれを待ったって
またん
示に死ぬ
[音楽]
goo
ああああああ
ああああああ今井んっ
ガチでやばいですねこれ家紅やがちょっとヤバかったなきゃっキロて練習しますどうぞ
にならせていきましょう
それって俺
さっきろそろぐらい
[音楽]
ます
県がた
ぜっまず不満で僕ぞ
[拍手]
次は一体にも急遽うっさいその後10キロでくれてるぞ
これが売ってるだが僕の補強で違う
[音楽]
goo
もうこれのマンゼロのでは無理だ
はぁ
[音楽]
ですか今の160キロですね多分普通にやっててもまずで打てないと思いませんです
それじゃあまず100キロで打つ感覚を覚えます109で浮く感覚を覚えた後3100
キロのスプールになれます目がに野球になってきて雨に充てるようにやれば多分てると
思うんでまず100キロで当てる練習させてください500れてしまっていますあ2
キロで練習しな
こんなバンドやってます本当に選手がない
ええええええ
山ガール
ん
私あみんなゲイナー俺がすごいんだった
ねえねえ
ねぇめぐみの女ねぇ
[拍手]
ああああああ
[音楽]
うわぁ
b 00 ee よっ
w
w ぼん
web じゃくって言って
weather day たまにがっちりでございます王族だ100キロねちょっと
当てる練習した後
癒しけどとか見まくって目を投げさせますなってますよね
ええええええ
dj
tan
car
ます
俺あーまをどんどんが与えようになったと思うんで旭化成はもう200キロに目をなっ
ちゃうわけです
200言うと私はいい
[音楽]
ええええええ
ネイル宮どうすればいいみる
村さん目で見えな女を並べばいい大においっ
ええええええ
雨8 b 8 b 8 b 8 b 8 b 8
グリーンだったよ on ear
ale
これでもいいけどいれば号車
w まああ良い
ちょっと待って当たっていいんだよライディマジェルカ月なんかな
web
20 e 4
ん
わかるようになってきたということはやってるが見えているということなんですよ
ただ卵てきてんぱいっても般若ないって状況れています
はい
笑ああああああ
上で結構な本数の200キロの魂見てきたねバンドが変わったのでボールが見えるよう
になりました実は200キロの様にはかなり慣れた桜かなと思いますかなぁ方がいい数
や竜たりもしたんであんまり目は200球に慣れてきたと思いますということはですよ
今の俺なら再構成
760キロくらいだったら多分いい感じに当たるんじゃないかなと思います見て下さい
審議しておりゃー
逆に空虚だけどさーちんっ
なおえん
me
teal
rar あった